[Musique]
les médias en général sont loin d'être
parfait quand vient le temps de
rapporter les résultats d'études
scientifiques le piège du
sensationnalisme et la quête déclic
viennent souvent brouillé les cartes et
favoriser la désinformation alors
bouchra les jours se suivent et se
ressemblent vraiment quand on regarde ça
les articles des publications gauche à
droite qui vante les mérites des
aliments soit plus dur de s'y retrouver
de sorts qu'est ce qui est vraiment bon
pour notre santé et qu'est-ce qu'il est
carrément pas mais oui justement avec ti
ça va être sûr que selon certains
articles
le g100 aiderait à perdre du poids
l'huile d'olive aiderait à combattre la
démence ou encore la diète cet âge n
aiderait à combattre la gueule je vous
respecte beaucoup alors ceci toutes des
choses qui ont été mis dans les grands
titres dans des médias sur internet mais
en fait quand on regarde les petits
détails on se rend compte que c'est
souvent des études qui ont été faites
sur des souris et qui sont loin de
pouvoir se transposer à l'humain il ya
des sites web ou des feux de voitures
plutôt qui nous aide un peu a départagé
qu'est-ce qui vaut vraiment la peine des
crues comme nouvelle oui et justement il
ya un chercheur qui s'appelle james
hunter et lui j'en avais un peu assez de
voir six titres sensationnalistes il ya
décidé de partir un compte twitter qui
s'appelle just 16 et de maïs quand ils
voient des études qui sont faites sur
des souris et mais qui ne le précise pas
dans le titre donc lui partage l'étude
émet en majuscules dans les souris pour
que les lecteurs sachent cette étude là
ça aurait dû être précisés dans titre
quand l'étude a été rapporté dans les
médias
donc ce qu'il dit ce chercheur le sait
qu'il n'ya pas de problème fondamental
avec les études qui sont faits sur les
souris mais si l'étude est seulement été
faite sur des souris on ne peut pas
encore s'avancer à laisser croire aux
gens que ça va fonctionner pour les
humains ça peut donner faussement de
l'espoir à des gens qui attendent
justement un traitement pour ces
maladies est vraiment génial cet hiver
que c'est la seule s qui en a d'autres
qui calque un peu le même modèle
d'intervention sur les réseaux sociaux
donc il ya d'autres personnes qui lui
ont emboîté le pas il ya un autre conte
qui s'appelle justin watts donc qui
soulignent les études qui sont faits sur
les rats mais il ya d'autres façon dont
les médias rapportent la science et qui
parfois est un peu problématique
par exemple quand on rapporte les
risques alors si on dit
le bacon double le risque de crise
cardiaque on a l'impression que c'est
vraiment très grave mais si on regarde
les chiffres on peut se rendre compte
que le risque passe en fait de cette sur
1000 à 14 sur 1000
le risque reste très infime donc un
compte twitter qui soulignent ces
aberrations la qui s'appelle just 16
risques et l'autre problème qu'on peut
voir des fois si des études qui sont
faits sur des très petits échantillons
sept autres comptes twitter locke qui
s'appelle 16 cm pour size lui partagent
les études en précisant la taille de
l'échantillon donc un exemple récent
c'était une étude qui a été faite qui
dit que le vin rouge contient un
ingrédient qui aident à combattre la
perte de muscles et que ça pourrait
aider les astronautes qui partent dans
l'espace et dont les muscles rapetisse
mais en fait quand on regarde
l'échantillon on voit que non seulement
ça a été fait sur des rats mais que les
faits étaient mesurées seulement sur ce
sera donc un très petit échantillon
j'imagine que d'autres choses qu'on est
en mesure de faire construire citoyens
qu'on soit journaliste pour mieux se
guider à travers tout ça oui donc il ya
des leçons à tirer de ce premièrement
pour le public c'est de ne pas s'arrêter
au gratuit si on veut partager par
exemple un article sur les réseaux
sociaux
prendre le temps de lire voir les
détails voit vraiment c'était quoi le
contexte de l'étude
et pour les journalistes c'est de ne pas
faire des titres sensationnalistes donc
si l'étude seulement été fait sur des
souris de lui même dans le titre même si
ça va peut-être avoir l'air moins
impressionnant saut jamais à moins de
clics
exactement parce que finalement si la
meilleure façon d'informer les gens sur
la recherche scientifique c'est ce qu'on
veut au final